tombé à boston donc hier soir et après
mick jagger notre jojo national johnny
hallyday il fait son retour au cinéma
avec jean rochefort dans un film de
patrice leconte l'homme du train un film
très bien accueillis à la mostra de
venise où il est en compétition sur la
lagune
marie-jo jouant à la location le
monument du rock français ici à la
mostra qui aurait pu le croire même pas
lui comme un gosse johnny profite enfin
de l'univers dont il a toujours rêvé en
secret patrice leconte a osé le faire
l'associer à jean rochefort 72 ans
acteur fétiche du réalisateur
je peux vous demander quelque chose est
sûre vous pourriez me prêter des bantous
et pourquoi tu es mal aux pieds
une vraie amitié c'est à la vie à un
homme sans amitié d'intrigants
mais nous là on est deux on forme une
équipe car c'est d'une histoire d'amitié
donc il s'agit aussi virique improbable
entre un prof de français à la retraite
est un braqueur de banques raté à leur
dire confusément là aurait bien voulu
avoir la vie de l'autre pas évident
d'être confronté aux ténors de la scène
et jean rochefort
on savait qu'il avait le coeur tendre on
apprend que johnny 59 ans se remet
toujours en question m'a regardé
très inquiet dans les humains dit on va
rire un peu dans le film on va rire
c'est fait oui et je me suis posé la
question je lui dis qu'est-ce qui va pas
que je fasse préférions
il est gentil il est sympathique quoi
vous étiez avant preuve en 30 ans
d'enseignement passe à l'accouchement
sexuelle à me reprocher chapeau le film
a été écrit pour eux deux ils acceptent
de faire le film
c'est ce qui peut arriver de mieux à un
metteur en scène parce que c'est plus
facile de travailler qu'à stradivarius
qu'avec un crack dernière cascades et il
semblerait que les scénarios fonctionne
aussi bien dans la vie que dans le champ
des hérons ça bouge pas le héros -
briand partition à deux voix placée sous
le signe de l'humour
l'homme du train a conquis le public de
la mostra de venise 20 minutes
d'applaudissements debout et pourquoi
pas un film français pour le lion d'or
on verra